[MUSIC]
Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our webcast MBA Student
Insights A Q and A with GSP pride.
My name is Eddy Bueser, and
I'm a first year MBA student here
at the Stanford Graduate School of
Business, and a co president of GSP pride.
And I'm joined here by Detren,
Prince Yu and Jack Armstrong,
and like me they are also current MBA
students and GSP pride code members.
We'll be talking about our
personal journey to the GSB,
the LGBTQ experience here on campus,
and the GSB Pride Club and community.
And we're going to try to answer as
many of your questions as we can.
To submit a question to us you can click
on the Q and A button at the bottom
of your screen and we will be talking
about the admissions process,
the application of the financial aid,
but you can contact the MBA admissions
office directly by emailing
mba.admissions@gsb.stanford.edu.
So, before we begin it would be great if
we can begin with some introductions to
Duke Vince and Jack, if you can start
by telling us a little bit more about
yourselves, where you're from, what you
were doing before coming to the GSB and
what your goals are after graduation?
That would be great.
So, Jack, do you want to start?
>> Hi, Yeah so, Jack, originally from
the UK, first time living in the US.
Before school I was a turnaround
administration consultant working
with the Distressed Businesses.
I'm hoping to figure out what
I want to do after school.
I think it looks something
like working with private
film portfolio teams but
still working on it.
>> Vince?
>> Hi, I'm Vincent Yu, I was born and
raised in the Philippines.
I grew up there, studied there all my
life, and prior to coming to the GSB,
I was an oil and
gas salesman in the Philippians, and
thereafter I was in consulting
with Bain in Singapore.
What I plan to do after GSB, I'm
actually a sponsored student by Vane, so
I'm heading back, but
I'm joining their San Francisco office.
>> Hi, I'm Duc, originally from San Jose,
California, so just down the street.
Prior to the GSB I lived in DC for
six years working in government and
in international development.
And post GSB still figuring out but
probably somewhere in consulting or
tech yeah.
>> And I can just wrap up with myself,
I’m originally from North Jersey,
I grew up in Hasbrouck Heights,
New Jersey and Burton County.
Before the GSB, I was working
in New York City at Bain Company
like Vince and I worked my
fourth year in the Paris office.
After graduation, I am a sponsored student
as well and I'll be going back into
consulting in New York, and for the long
term I'm still trying to figure that out.
So just to kick off the first question,
what is the LGBTQ community like at the
GSB and what about the campus at large?
And what kinds of support involvement and
interaction does the rest of the class
have with the GSB Pride Community.
So Jack and Vince,
do you want to kick that one off?
>> Sure.
>> Jack, go ahead.
>> Yeah, so I think the community of
the GSB has been fantastic, and for
me personally, it's the first time
I've really engaged in the community,
and didn't really prior to school.
And so for me it's been really warm,
really welcoming, very friendly.
I think what's nice is the relationship
between the NBA one class and the NBA two
class kind of turning up on campus and
having some funny faces to the community.
And also think kind of allyship that
you see in the class more probably.
>> Yeah definitely, I would like to stress
on the allyship because having grown up in
south east Asia was just relatively
more conservative than the Bay Area.
It's definitely been quite refreshing
how accepting everyone's been and
how many allies are in class.
It's as if, again coming from
a place where my identity
is almost attacked on
TV on a daily basis and
moving to a place where it's just
celebrated is very refreshing.
That end of GSB and
also in the campus at large.
>> yeah thanks, and
building off that point,
can you guys talk about your experiences
specifically with GSB Pride?
Can you talk about some of the social
events that Pride organizes throughout
the year, any other types of events
that Pride sponsors or organizes?
So I might throw that one to you,
Duke, and then Jack as well.
>> Sure,
I mean I love the Pride group here,
I think pride is really
what you make of it.
So we meet about up once a week
to catch up with each other,
both classes which as Jack mentioned,
a really valuable thing for me.
We also do alumni,
we have an alumni reception once a year.
We attend rumba,
which is the LGBT conference in the fall.
We do National Coming Out Day.
I think we host informal small group
dinners where we get to know one another,
so lots of events throughout the year.
>> Yeah what I think is really
nice is the touch point of that
kind of weekly social event that we have.
It's just a nice way of coming together.
You can bring allies, you can bring
friends and people just get together and
sit, and sometimes you talk politics,
much of which I don't understand
as a Brit, I'm trying to avoid it.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But
then everything from that,
from things going on in the community, or
school more broadly, and
it's just a nice space to be able
to get together in a no-pressure
environment once a week, which is nice.
>> Do either of you have a favorite
GSB pride event from this past year
that was especially memorable to you?
>> I think the event was fantastic,
I think you realize that they're not only
rock stars in their lives, but they're
like rock stars in terms of the community,
a lot of them which is fantastic to see
them, and for them to just be so open
to getting to know us, and helping and
supporting I think that was great for me.
>> Yeah.
For me,
I really enjoyed rumba in the fall.
It was a great first event for entering
students, got to know a bunch of my
classmates, and met a bunch of new
people from different schools.
>> Great.
So talking a little bit more
about what the GSB life is and
how that intertwines with the GSB Pride
community, can a few of you talk about
your involvement in social and
professional clubs other than GSB Pride?
So Vince you want to talk
about your experiences?
>> Sure, so
I'm a co-president of two clubs currently.
First is,
I'm a co-president of the game club which
is basically a bunch of geeks
talking about video games,
pursuing video as professional career,
so that's pretty great.
Second is I'm also co-president of
the Asia Business Students Association,
and what I find is when they find like
coming from Asia and going into foreign
country in the US, I found I never really
appreciated my identity as an Asian
until I actually came to a geography
which has a lot of ethnic diversity.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah and that's,
being part of both GSP Pride and
the Asian Business Student Association has
helped me appreciate both layers of my
identity.
>> The intersectionality
between those two.
Yeah, and I guess apart from that, we're
also planning a Philippines Global of
Study trip, so
hopefully that comes through.
>> Awesome I guess I can talk to that
as well from my own experiences.
So aside from being in GSB Pride,
I am also an Arbuckle Leadership Fellow.
So the Arbuckle Leadership Program
is designed for second-year MBAs and
help second year MBAs learn how
to develop and coach others and
be more effective at coaching and
developing others.
And so we take specific classes
throughout the fall quarter and
the spring quarter now And in the fourth
quarter when the first year MBAs arrive we
actually take leadership of a squad
of five or six first year MBAs.
And help and develop them to become
better and more effective leaders through
simulated leadership exercises
throughout the quarter.
So it's a really awesome experience.
I've definitely been learning a lot ever
since joining the program and I feel like
I've been developing my leadership skills
in a new and unique way here at the GSB.
So shifting away from
the pride community and
extra-curricular activities, I want to
talk a little bit more about career plans.
So what are your career plans and
how has your experience at the GSB helped
shape what you might
want to do in the future?
I might throw that to you,
Jack, to answer that one first.
>> Yeah, so I think in terms of
how the GSB has helped shape
how I think about career plans.
I think you're just surrounded by 800,
across the 2 classes,
amazing people who've done a massive
range of interesting things.
And so I think the first way
it kind of impacted me was it
showed me the art of the possible in
terms of the opportunities out there,
roles I'd never even heard of or
thought about.
So I think that was really powerful, just
being able to speak to, and engage with
people, and really dig into what those
kind of opportunities look like.
And then I think more broadly
the resources on campus,
things like the career management center,
is a fantastic resource,
whether that's helping you think
about what you want to do.
Which I know I went in with
a blank piece of paper and
came out with several really good options.
And then they help you through
every step of that process,
whether it be interview prep,
CV reviews or
kind of negotiating internship
opportunities and full time roles.
I'm looking to transition
into private equity, and
specifically operating
within private equity.
And lots of our classmates
come from various firms and
have been really helpful with that.
In particular several members of the pride
community have put me in touch with
their previous employers or people
that they're in conversations with and
have helped make that connection for
me, yeah.
>> How about you, Duke?
>> Yeah, let me say my career
path has been pretty evolving.
I echo Jack that the care services has
been super helpful in thinking about
designing what your career would be and
strategies on how to engage with alums,
and even your Professors on how
to think about your career.
So I came into the GSB thinking
that I wanted to do consulting,
and I may still do that, but I'm also
exploring tech, specifically to get back
whether or not, like I would
product management, for example.
And I think that's what's
great about the GSB,
is you can talk to people who
are experts in the field and
it really iterate on what you want and
what you're good at.
>> And I think just to add on that I
have one specific example of kind of
the community aspect.
A couple of months back there was
a company on campus, and the day before I
saw one of our classmates who I had
spoken to about what I wanted to do.
And he came up to me and was just like
hey, these guys are on campus tomorrow.
I've already dropped them an email to
let them know that you're interested and
this is your background.
Because he had made the connection
between what I wanted to do and
what they were talking about.
I would've totally missed that
opportunity if that hadn't happened.
That was totally proactive on that part,
so I think the community aspect
is really important on that.
>> Just to add to the community aspect.
I know I mentioned a while ago that
I'm actually headed back to Bain, but
I think what the GSB has helped me figure
out is what I want to do in the long term,
say five to ten years down the line.
I also mentioned that I'm part of
the game club, and through the game club,
I actually was able to network with
lots of people from the gaming industry.
I met a lot of people from big
companies like Activision Blizzard,
EA Games and what not.
And really, these conversations with
these different sorts of people who
are passionate about their craft sort
of have inspired me to pursue gaming,
at least this summer.
So this summer, what I'm actually going to
do is I'm going to be working as a product
manager for a midsized gaming
company in San Francisco.
I'm working on a video game called
War Dragons, helping create dragons for
people who are going to play that game on
their phone, so that's pretty interesting.
>> Yeah, that's awesome.
>> [LAUGH] Actually, I want to pick upon
a thing that all of you touched upon,
which was your interactions
with employers on campus and
how supportive that the pride
community has been in that.
But talking a little bit more about
your interactions with employers,
can you speak to whether you were out
in your interactions with them, and
generally how receptive have
employers been to your identity?
And if you can speak to experiences now or
experiences before the GSB,
please feel free to.
So I might toss that one to you,
Duke, first.
>> Yeah, for me I'm pretty
comfortable with being LGBT and
I know not a lot of people are,
so I've always been out at work.
And I personally believe
that it's important for
me to be able to come to work as my
full self, and even on my resume line,
I think I have a line that says like
enthusiastic RuPaul drag race fan.
[LAUGH] Just to make it clear.
>> How about you, Vince?
>> So I guess for
me it's been a stark contrast.
Having worked in oil and gas sales before,
I was actually told by a boss,
very early in my career that I
couldn't out myself to select
clients just because they're really
known to be homophobic and what not.
And my experience in the bay area,
because I've been primarily applying for
internships here, is that being out and
proud is a non factor.
Some people might argue that it might
actually give you some brownie points for
being a diversity candidate.
So if anything, being out and proud
while applying to different companies,
as a GSB person, is a good thing.
>> Good,
do you have anything to add, Jack?
>> Yeah, I think certainly, a lot of the
big employers are really good in engaging
with the community and helping with
that kind of process of applying.
And I think one of the things
that I noticed is that,
especially if you're talking to alumni or
companies with alumni about them,
that you come with this brand
that's already really powerful.
And actually they know so much about you,
and they've been part of the GSB
community before, so I think it's been
really well received in general, yeah.
>> All right, thanks for
your perspectives on that one.
I'm actually seeing that a bunch of
questions are coming in from the audience,
so I want to have some time to
answer some of those as well.
So the first question that I'm seeing
is hi team, thank you for time today.
You're welcome.
[LAUGH] I was wondering what is
the women to men ratio in the GSB Pride?
Just asking,
since you're all men in the panel today.
So that's a great point.
We do have a number of women in
GSB Pride who are super super active in
organizing a lot of
the activities that we do.
Just to give an example,
of the four presidents this past year,
three of them identified as women,
Alice, Jess, and Ellen.
We have a number of events that
occur throughout the year,
one of them most recently happened
in San Francisco, I believe.
It was a brunch that was attended
by over 25 plus GSB Pride women and
alumni from around the bay area.
So there's a super,
super active community.
I can't give exact numbers on
the ratio and percentage right now,
because I don't know them
off the top of my head.
But they certainly are a big part of our
community and an important one as well.
And then another question that
we got was when applying,
were you out on your application?
Could you discuss how you communicated it?
Does anybody want to take one of those?
>> Yeah, I can take it.
I was definitely out on my application.
Mostly because I had talked about it in
my essay and what you know coming out.
And being from my family's
pretty Catholic and
how that shaped me into
the person that I am today.
And I was involved in a bunch
of LGBT organizations too.
So, that was my [INAUDIBLE].
>> I did the exact thing too.
In my what matters most and
why I say talk about equality and
I think of course lots of elements of
equality that I was able to weave in were
from you know me being queer and
in Southeast Asia so
meeting out came out there and of course
your CV can communicate it as well.
>> How about you, Jack?
Were you on your application?
>> I don't think I was.
I think it's just, if it feels.
My thoughts on this all you have to
be authentic in your application and
if it authentically fits into
your story in your essay or
in your in other parts of your
application then certainly flag it.
Yeah, I think it's more about being
authentic to answering the questions.
>> Yeah, I think that's a great point.
And I've gotten this question a couple
times as well from perspective admits our
or my advice every time
has been if being LGBT and
if that part of your identity is
a huge part of who you are today,
what makes you a great leader, and what
makes you a great fit for the GSB, then
I would absolutely put it in your essays
or in other parts of your application.
What I wouldn't recommend is
putting it in just to put it in,
without any particular reason.
Because that's something that admission
definitely tries to tease out is who you
are as person and what kind of
value are you at the GSP community.
Other questions from the audience,
how active are the allies when it comes to
defending someone who identifies
as LGBTQ in a birth situation.
Do you have any interesting
situations to share?
I'll give you guys a couple
moments to think about that.
Or maybe to the first question,
how supportive have you perceived
allies to be on campus and would they come
to defend you in interesting situations?
>> I think, so
I think more broadly at the GSB,
I think there's very
rarely a situation where
I could see that happening in in any
form of diversity or any situation.
I don't think I've seen
an argument since being here,
unless it's a heated debate in in
a case or in in the classroom.
And I'd certainly see very often
people voicing opinions of those
are simple when discussing cases or or
just talking diversity more broadly,
a sense of allyship and
then people would step in and
certainly are involved in
the community just more probably.
>> Anyone else have any situations?
Like really, there's no situations that-
>> Yeah.
I guess it's just not an issue.
>> Yeah, I think that's the general
theme that I'm hearing from
all of you is that it doesn't really
seem to be an issue on campus.
That said,
we do benefit from being in the Bay Area,
we do benefit from being in California.
So we can't speak to all
environments everywhere.
But certainly at Stanford in
Palo Alto specifically there,
I've been out and pretty young,
I haven't experienced any issues.
>> Yeah.
>> I was just saying,
I think it's a healthy discussion.
I think one of the things that
happens a lot at the GSBs is
the healthy discussion around
a collection of topics.
Whether that be your identity,
whether that be diversity or
politics or career or so I think I've
been in a lot of situations that people
are certainly tested and challenged and
asked questions and thought about things.
And so
I think you see that happening a lot and
I think that's a healthy
debate that we see.
>> Yeah absolutely.
And I think on the allyship point
we have tremendous allies who
come to our Pride events all the time and
I know next year Eddy is planning on,
Doing more formal engagements or
socials with the different diversity clubs
out there with women in management group.
Yeah, do you want to
talk a bit about that?
>> Yes, so I think.
I'm sorry I had to think about
what you were referring to.
Yeah so we just got elected.
We just chose our new leadership
just a couple weeks ago.
So we've just been in the process of
putting together our agenda for next year.
And one of the things that we're really
focusing on, really organizing and
adding into the agenda,
are more community-focused initiatives and
specifically education-focused
initiatives.
Not just for GSB Pride but for
the broader Stanford and GSB community.
I think if there's one thing that we would
wish to do more as GSB Pride members is,
have the ability to have
open conversations with
other students within the GSB community.
We do receive a lot of questions about
how people can be a better ally.
So because of this interest,
we've just decided to have more
events around you know, just like casual
lunches but also formal asked me anything
type of events which we plan
on organizing for next year.
So that's all in the pipeline and
we're really kind of excited to kick,
kick off, kick all that off.
So I want to switch gears a little bit to
another audience question that was more
around the lines of how we chose to
come to Stanford versus other programs.
And what research we did to
really inform that twice.
So one question was,
''during the research phase of your MBA
application journey What questions
Did you ask alumni the GSB?
Or did you ask in general,
about other programs?
And how did that inform your decision to
choose Stanford over another program,
whether it was in the country or
internationally.
I might throw this one to you,
Jack because I know personally
you're making this choice.
>> Yeah, I probably did it in
a slightly unconventional way.
I definitely didn't plan
to do business school, and
so kind of a few months before round one I
downloaded the FT's top ten school list,
and kind of started from there.
And outside of the kind of year-round
sunshine that Stanford provides,
which was really important to me,
I think I thought about
what it was that I wanted to get
in terms of skills development.
And then I thought about how I'd
like to develop those skills.
And for me, it was a lot about
how is the course structured.
What flexibility do I have in that?
And then,
what's the community going to be like?
And I think for me that turning point
was admit weekend when I kind of
was looking at various options and
decided to come to on that weekend and
then I just had this weekend everybody
on that as well you are my people and so
I think that's a really important
factor that is hard to test for.
Through, you know, websites or
statistics, I think, for me,
it's what I want to spend two years
with and who do I want to go with.
So that was really important.
Yeah.
>> Do any of you have similar experiences?
>> I applied to, so
my application story was I,
that I just applied to the top three
schools, I got in a couple of them, and
ultimately the choice boiled
down to where my partner and
I could, my partner and I intended to move
to another country where we could get
married or have kids, and it seemed that
Stanford provided the perfect environment,
being in the Bay Area to make
the transition easy for us,
because whenever we have to fly back to
Manila, which is just a direct flight
from San Fransisco,
that flight will be easily available.
And to San Francisco is known
as the game mecca, so to speak.
So that is like that just makes
the whole transition less easier for us.
>> I can talk about my
own experience as well.
So for me I was really torn
in trying to decide between
Stanford or
an international school like INSEAD.
One of the benefits of going to
an international school is that you have
a little bit more of an international
focus which is great.
But at the end of the day what it
boils down to me was where did I feel
like I could develop most as a leader,
and having a two-year
program at Stanford to me kind of-
>> [COUGH]
>> A one year program at an international
school somewhere else.
So that's how I made my choice,
even though my fiancee is French and
definitely wanted me to go to INSEAD.
Had to let them down.
[LAUGH] So
switching gears now into Mentorship,
one question from the audience is,
how do you personally engage with mentors,
GSB alumni?
I know we talked about the alumni event,
but are there other avenues that any
of you have experienced with engaging with
any mentors or alumni through the network?
>> I think one of the things that you
get at the GSB is lots of moments
of mentorship that might not
specifically be a mentor.
So I was telling the guys just before
I came in that I did a small group
dinner with a faculty member here who is
a very successful VC in the Bay Area.
And at that small group dinner offered up
just kind of one on one conversations.
And two, three weeks later
I'm start having coffee for
30 minutes talking about
anything that was on my agenda.
Whether that was whether I wanted to
pitch a startup idea or whether I wanted
to talk about my career, or
how to manage the world that is the GSB.
That's one example of where that
mentorship happens in the moment.
I know I think my favorite class of the
first quarter is managerial skills where
basically, you get these rock stars who
come in and teach you basically how to
hire people, how to fire people,
how to manage difficult conversations.
And again we did this small group
dinner with our faculty member there,
we had follow-up coffees, and
these are people that you couldn't get
time with if you tried in the real world.
And so I think you get lots of moments of
small mentorship, which I think you can
grow then into longer term
relationships if it feels right.
>> Yeah, and
I've had a similar experience as well,
when I attended the reaching out
MBA conference this past fall.
I had met a GSB Pride alumni
there who I didn't know before at
a reception at Google, and
him and I connected immediately.
After the reception, he was absolutely
instrumental in helping me through
the process and helping me with
interviews, helping me with questions.
So I really, really felt like he,
he wanted me to succeed.
And I think without that GSB pride
connection, I'm not sure if I would have
been able to connect with any
other recruiter at the conference,
because of that.
So that's just one example.
I mean I think the punch line here
is like we found the alumni really,
really supportive even if we only see them
a couple times per year at ad hoc events.
They're always there for support.
>> I guess we also haven't touched
on is MBA too, as mentors, so
during your first year you take this
class called Leadership Labs in which
you're assigned an Arbuckle
leadership fellow.
They'll lead you along with a group of six
in leadership development exercises where
you pick up different soft skills and
what not.
And I found that to be
a very good mentorship tool.
And in the two succeeding quarters
you can actually get paired
with a personal leadership coach in
the form of an Arbuckle Leadership Fellow,
who will meet up with you seven or
eight times to fulfill whatever
leadership needs you have.
And for me, that was very powerful
because in those specific moments,
I had particular conversations I had
to have with regard to say, trying to
push a job offer, or for example, extend
the deadline of a job offer and whatnot.
So that time with that coach as
very invaluable, and yeah, what I'm
trying to say is MBA 2 is, can serve as
mentors, it serves as mentors as well.
And I guess just to allude to what Jack
said, I learned so much from MBA 1 through
our season, and experienced different
sorts of environments and industries that
I may treat them as mentors for particular
things in other times, for certain topics.
>> Awesome.
On that topic of leadership actually,
another question submitted by
the audience is what are you learning
about leadership while at the GSB
that you didn't already know?
And this is a really,
really important question so
I'd like for, I guess for
everybody to answer it.
Do you want to start?
>> Yeah, I mean I think one thing
that I've learned is the power of
vulnerability in the context of
management that it helps build trust
that it helps folks connect with you
that you are managing or working with.
I think that came as a surprise for me.
Because I'm not naturally vulnerable.
But I think there are tons of
opportunities at the GSP to practice that
muscle.
And really build that trust
with your classmates.
>> Actually vulnerability was
the first answer that came to my head.
But because Duke took it-
>> [LAUGH]
>> I guess not leadership in particular,
but developing leadership skills.
I think what I learned that was
very valuable at the GSB was
immerse yourself in situations that,
like What came to mind was the value
of role playing and what not.
Basically, what I'm leading
to is just keep immersing
yourself in situations that
you think you may experience
in the future that you feel
like getting what you like.
Immerse yourself in situations
that you feel will help develop
your leadership skills in the future.
>> Yeah.
>> So, say for
example in that Arbuckle Leadership class
we would role play certain things like
firing an employee, hiring an employee.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Having a difficult conversation with
someone like two layers above, and just
emerging yourself in those situations that
you could potentially face in the future,
like will end up developing those skills.
>> Yeah.
I think one thing you hear a lot here is
that leadership is a set of behaviors
rather than something that is intrinsic to
a specific person.
So I think to build on what you were
saying, that if you've put yourself into
situations where you are able
to build on those behaviors and
exercise those behaviors,
you will become a better leader.
>> Yeah.
How about you, Jack?
>> I think for me, leadership comes in so
many forms and it's very personal.
I think one of the things we talked about
is leadership [INAUDIBLE] program and
basically, the ultimate question is why
would somebody follow you as a leader?
And at the end of the course, you
basically go around as a team and say why
you would or wouldn't follow everybody as
a leader, and no one answers the same.
And I think everybody, there is a reason
that everybody can be a leader and
there is these things that make them
really impactful as a leader, and
that might be a variety of things.
So you can take a set of tools, a set of
behaviors, make it authentic to you, and
that's what's going to
make you successful.
If you try and play a playbook,
it's not going to work.
And I think that's what's nice is
really getting the feedback and
understanding like why people follow you
and what behaviors work for you, and
also seeing the different
types of leadership play out.
>> Yeah, and just to add on to what
everybody said, one of the first things
that I thought about during that question
is vulnerability and openness as well.
Which I think just speaks to how
Stanford has hit this concept home for
everybody, on a repeated basis, and
just to provide an example of how
that's incorporated in our curriculum.
One of the classes that I'm taking right
now is called Interpersonal Dynamics,
a.k.a, touchy feely,
and it's really one of the cornerstone
classes of the GSB experience.
And it’s essentially a class in which
you learn all the different models and
concepts on how to understand how
to communicate with others and
why breakdowns in communications happen,
why conflicts occur between people.
And part of the class is
literally sitting in a room
with 13 other people in a circle for
three hours at a time, and
just letting the communication unfold.
And it sounds super ambiguous and
unstructured,
but I've had two classes so
far and it's been absolutely
riveting to just sit in this group and
to see how communication unfolds and
taking risks and
expressing how you actually feel is such
an out of the comfort zone for me, but I'm
kind of understanding now how that would
make me a better leader in the future.
So a lot of things that were unexpected
for me coming into the GSB about
leadership, but
I'm definitely learning a lot.
So, and we have about ten minutes or
so left.
So I think we can answer
a few other questions,
there's a question from
the audience around how being
LGBTQ has informed how you show up and
be present in the classroom.
So does anyone have any thoughts about if
you made a contribution that was informed
by your identity?
Or whether you viewed
something a different way or
brought a new perspective
because you were LGBTQ?
Any experiences like that in
the classroom or in group meetings?
>> I guess not in particular
in the classroom but
I guess one thing we
can talk about is talk.
>> Yeah.
>> So talk is like a weekly event in which
we get two of our classmates to speak
in front of the whole student body and
share maybe for 30 to 45 minutes
just their life story and whatnot.
Yeah.
>> And I guess so
I had my talk last quarter and
year three has ended, thank you.
>> [LAUGH] It was great.
>> It was fantastic, yeah.
>> So I had my talk last quarter, and that
just gave me a venue to tell people about
my identity and my journey to the GSB and
my journey in life thus far.
And a lot of that involved my
identity as a queer person.
And I feel like that just
served as a venue for
me to share my life story to everyone.
And hopefully people, queer and
not queer were able to just
take something from that.
>> Yeah.
>> I think for me something that I think
about is sort of coming into school I
very much played a role at work
during turn around and crisis and
it was very much relatively straight faced
and I was there to do a specific thing.
And I think I came into the classroom
a little bit like that,
thinking this is business,
this is business school,
let's talk about whatever
the case is in front of us.
And then what I've seen is all my
classmates bringing in this wider
perspective around who they are as
a person and their identity and
bringing that to the conversations
that we're having, and
I've seen how powerful that's been.
And so I think less and less am I
disconnecting who I am and what I'm doing
and bringing more of myself to those
conversations into the classroom so
I think for me it's still a process I'm
going through, but I have definitely
seen how it's been impactful in
the conversation that we've been having.
>> Yeah, and I can just talk from my,
I did not personally do this but
I know of someone who made
an informed comment in class where
it was our marketplaces class and
we were talking about dating apps
as a form of marketplaces and
someone that I know actually
raised their hand and
pointed out to the professor
in the classroom that
we're looking at dating apps from
a very heteronormative perspective and
we should also consider
the implications of a marketplace for
a queer dating app, or like,
Tinder, or same-sex dating app.
So it was a really insightful,
I found that to be a super,
super insightful comment.
And to be a very brave comment, as well.
But I could literally see people's
faces changing in the room from,
to just being curious, but
to just a broader understanding of,
these are issues that we actually need to
think about and we need to be aware of.
When talking about the real world.
So I thought that was a really, really
cool experience that I witnessed recently.
I think another question, this one is
a little bit more about social life.
At the GSB-LGBTQ night life at the GSB so
we can answer this one
really quickly because I know I was
curious, at least, when I was playing.
How is LGBTQ night life near the GSB?
What do we do?
Are there venues, do we organize things on
campus or do we go out to San Francisco?
Kind of leading you guys
to that answer right now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I think one of the fantastic things
about business school,
whether it be pride specific or
non, if you got 50 really interesting
people in a room, you can make a party.
That's really easy to do.
So is Palo Alto the best night
life in the world, absolutely not.
Do you need it to be, absolutely not.
We have our weekly PGPG,
which is our kind of happy hour for
pride, which we really make
the most of and enjoy.
And then we head up to the city for
various events, or just to go and
enjoy the night life every
few weeks probably I think.
>> Yeah, I think we go up to the city
pretty often, one or twice a month.
There's a good chunk of
your social life is also
traveling with your classmates over
the weekend, so I would say that
that has been the constraining factor in
terms of how often we go up to the city.
So not necessarily like
that Palo Alto was bad.
Which it is but
there's other stuff out there.
>> Yeah, I would say, so
one question that I had that I know
that some others might have is
how accessible is San Francisco?
Cause Vince you mentioned that
San Francisco is a very welcoming city to
people who identify as LGBTQ,
and it absolutely is.
San Francisco is super,
super accessible from Palo Alto.
You can either take
a public transportation,
like a train there, and it gets you there
in like, correct me if I'm wrong, like?
>> 35 minutes.
>> 35 minutes to an hour or
if it's at night and
you want to go to experience
some of the night life.
I know that we kind of just pile into
an Uber and split the Uber four ways and
it winds up being really
economical to get there and back.
>> Sometimes we take a bus, so we've done
events as well where we've gone with other
schools and other grads kind of
students and we've gone up and
done kind of bigger overnight trips
up to the city and back as well.
>> Yeah, for sure.
So we have five minutes left, so
we want to end on one question and
that's, what do you find most rewarding so
far about the Stanford experience?
Jack, do you want to go?
>> Yeah, my answer is a compound answer.
It's really easy, it's the people.
>> Yeah, [LAUGH].
>> And
I think You're basically surrounded by 420
classmates who have your back,
are really, really interesting,
care deeply about one or
many things that they're passionate about.
And so I think the most rewarding thing
is how my mind has been opened up to so
many opportunities and so
many interesting conversations.
And how those friendships and
relationships are only
going to continue to grow,
whether that be from a professional
perspective or personal perspective.
I think the most rewarding part is getting
to do it with this group of people.
Especially these guys.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I guess apart from yeah,
Jack put it very well.
My first answer would
definitely be the people,
the network you could get out of
the business school experience.
But for me personally I think what
I gained from the GSB most thus
far is just being able to explore
gaming as a long-term career.
Because having had multiple conversations
with different people about gaming,
potentially interning for
a gaming company this summer
really solidified my hypothesis or
my thesis of trying to test whether
I want to do gaming in the long term.
And I feel that if I
hadn't gone to the GSB,
I wouldn't even be trying to
pursue this thing long term.
So that may have potentially dictated what
I'm going to do for the rest of my life,
and I think that's very valuable.
And another thing we were talking about is
the opportunity to take Tyra Banks' class
in spring.
>> [LAUGH]
>> She’s lurking around campus right now
as we do this right now.
>> She is on campus for that.
>> Some people saw her
30 minutes ago [LAUGH].
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
I would also echo that people
are absolutely critical, and
I have met tremendous people here who are
friendly, caring, interesting, super nice.
So I would say that is top.
I think for me also time is a huge thing,
in terms of you are super
busy at the MBA program.
But you have a lot of time for
self reflection, for career exploration,
to learn about anything you want,
essentially.
What's great about the GSB is you can
also take classes outside the GSB at
other schools than Stanford.
So it's basically a two-year
opportunity to meet great people,
learn super interesting things,
and just reflect on who you are as
a person and what you value.
>> Yeah, and just to wrap up for
the group before we go,
I think the most rewarding part
about the Stanford experience for
me is having an opportunity to take
risks in a low risk environment.
So before coming to the GSB,
I considered myself a really,
really risk averse person, both in the
workplace, but also in my personal life.
And just we've only been at the GSB for
what, like seven months now?
>> Yeah.
>> And it's completely changed my
perspective on what it
means to take risks.
So I'm doing activities that I would never
have done before outside of the GSB,
like I'm taking a swim class when
I had no idea how to swim before.
I'm testing new ways to express myself.
I'm testing new ways to communicate
with others almost on a daily basis.
And it's really, really exciting and scary
at times, but it's all for the learning.
And I can't stress this enough that being
at Stanford is a low risk environment,
and they really cultivate you to learn
how to be a person that takes risks.
And that's been by far and away the
biggest benefit, so far, in my first year.
So we'll see what's in store for
us in our second year.
But I'm really,
really excited for that and
sad as well that we're almost halfway
through our experience [LAUGH] together.
But anyway, I think that's all
the time that we have today.
So thank you to the three of you for
coming and participating.
Thank you everyone in the audience for
tuning in to the live webcast.
You can learn more about
the MBA program by visiting
the GSB website at gsb.stanford.edu.
And I think that's it for us.
Also, if you have questions
about the Pride group,
feel free to email
gsb_pride-leadership@stanford.edu as well.
But thank you again, and have a great day.
[MUSIC]